and now to the 2024 race for the White
House on Saturday President Biden held
his first campaign rally since
announcing that he's running for a
second term and some of his Republican
Challengers focus more on the GOP
front-runner and the federal criminal
charges that he faces Ed O'Keefe is at
the White House with more on the story
Ed good morning to you last race
President Biden wasn't on the road very
much because of covet let's see what the
strategy is this time around good
morning to you we will see exactly Gail
happy Monday to you a day after he
received the endorsement from the
AFL-CIO President Biden took his message
directly to its members highlighting his
administration's accomplishments while
leaving on any mention of potential
rival former president Donald Trump
President Biden back before a friendly
crowd of union workers in Philadelphia
for the first rally of his re-election
bid I'm proud to be the most pro-union
president in American history
the president pressing his economic
agenda making his case for another term
we've got a record to run on and most
importantly we're not only changing this
country we're transforming it but in a
new CBS News poll 42 percent of
Democrats think the 80-year-old
president shouldn't run for re-election
of those 45 percent say the reason is
whether he could finish the second term
Mr Biden's rally came days after GOP
front-runner former president Donald
Trump was arraigned on federal charges
for his handling of classified documents
this was a case that entirely of his own
making and while Trump has pleaded not
guilty and maintains the charges are
politically motivated his former
Attorney General Unleashed sharp
personal criticism Sunday he's a very
Petty individual who will always put his
interests ahead of the countries his
personal gratification of his you know
of his ego but our country our country
can't you know can't be a therapy
session for you know a troubled man like
this and some of Trump's presidential
Rivals are also taking issue with his
alleged actions the allegations in the
indictment are serious and uh I can't
defend what is alleged he's closest
competitor Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
avoided any direct criticism of trump
but tried drawing a contrast there is no
substitute for victory and we've
developed a culture of losing in this
party
now today President Biden heads out west
of California to focus on climate
initiatives and the effects of climate
change another priority for his
administration that his campaign hopes
will continue drawing contrast with
Republicans but then he's attending a
handful of closed-door fundraisers with
wealthy Bay Area donors one tonight Nate
and two more tomorrow
all right Ed good to see you thank you